it was a consequential week for two key
Trump administration immigration
policies on Tuesday a federal judge said
the daca program would shield some young
people from deportation must stay in
place and accept new applicants he
called the administration's decision to
rescind daca arbitrary and capricious
because the department failed adequately
to explain its conclusion that the
program was unlawful and on Wednesday
the Supreme Court heard arguments in the
travel ban case that restricts
immigration from eight countries
six of which have majority Muslim
populations here to discuss these cases
is Teresa Cardinal Brown she's director
of immigration and cross-border policy
at the Bipartisan Policy Center Teresa
good morning thanks for being here the
daca ruling and travel ban here in come
just a week after a federal case federal
judge rather ruled against the
Department of Justice in a case in
Chicago about sanctuary cities yeah
we'll get to all the specifics here but
are you seeing a pattern developing here
well so clearly there's been a pattern
of litigation against the policies of
this president since the beginning the
travel ban that he announced shortly
after his inauguration was the subject
of immediate litigation that weekend is
people remember there were protests and
chaos the travel in case the Supreme
Court heard this week is sort of the
culmination of all of that we're on the
third iteration of the travel ban and
what you're seeing is a set of policies
that the president promised on the
campaign trail he got elected he's
trying to carry out but in sort of
rushing to do so it doesn't always go
through what what most people would say
would be the proper procedure and sort
of so for example the docket case the
judge basically said you didn't do your
homework you didn't figure out the
appropriate legal way to end this
program whether or not that's right or
wrong but you didn't do it properly you
can't just rush into things and so
you're seeing the administration sort of
slowly catch up with the policies of the
president of the judges issue there was
procedural yes yeah it was very much
procedural so what does this say to the
dreamers out there so the judge did say
that unless the administration can come
up with a better legal reasoning for why
it's ending the program it has to reopen
the
so for the dreamers out there it's it's
wait a minute there's 90 days for the
government to come back and say give us
a better legal rationale but if they
can't then the judge will order the
complete program to restarted and that
means that people who were not eligible
to apply before me because they were too
young can now apply but there's 90 days
so nobody she rushed out and found just
yet let's talk about this Chicago case
what exactly happened there and you
think this may be even more significant
well the shark is is one of several
cases that have been filed now about
sanctuary cities a couple months ago
people remember the government sued the
state of California over its sanctuary
policies the Chicago case the city of
Chicago sued the Department of Justice
because they were trying to take away
federal funding for their police
officers based on whether or not the
city was cooperating on immigration and
they basically said look these grants
are set in statute Congress has said the
reasons that you can or cannot give a
city and immigration isn't on that list
you can't just arbitrarily pick other
things that you want us to do and the
judge agreed and very strenuous terms
that Department of Justice can't make
this stuff up so what does this travel
ban essentially do I mean when you think
about it what effect has it had so the
the travel ban now has been mostly in
place after a preliminary ruling from
the Supreme Court last fall and what
what this newest really ruling is
basically about was it done properly
does the government have the authority
but what we've seen is a response to
this iterations of the travel ban is
actually fewer people come in United
States especially from predominantly
Muslim countries we've seen declines in
foreign students we've seen declines in
visitors and you know a lot of people
were thinking that basically the United
States may have pulled back the welcome
mat all right Teresa Cardinal Brown
thanks for being here this morning we
appreciate it thanks for having me